pour la seconde année le musée léon
dierx collabore avec le conservatoire
régional afin de proposer au public
trois jours de variété française et de
musique classique
à l'occasion de la fête de la musique
elle tiendrait entre mes doigts
c'est chantant s'ils chantent encore la
boue sur toi
une façon originale de faire découvrir
le musée comme la collection du musée
dit collection de peintures du xixème
siècle donc les trois jours il ya
essentiellement des concerts de musique
classique où on pourra découvrir des
grands noms de l'époque du 19e comme
chopin fauré mais aussi des gens moins
connus
et parmi les moins connus il y a le
frère de gustave caillebotte dont on a
un tableau mais l'envers et on va
pouvoir écouter ce qu écrivait comme
musique son propre père martial
caillebotte debussy fauré de fontaine ou
encore cap les ces grands noms de la
musique classique seront interprétées
par les professeurs et les élèves du
conservatoire à rayonnement régional
il ya un objectif artistique qui est
livré cette année la musique française
c'est de trouver une thématique
artistique et de la livrée au public une
idée c'est de sortir de nos murs pour à
la rencontre d'un public on a notre
public avec les élèves répartis mais
aller dans le musée c'est aussi croiser
le public du musée
voilà rencontrer un autre public que
celui qu'on a l'habitude de voir de la
musique au musée une idée apprécié par
les organisateurs mais aussi par le
public
ce formidable
franchement le concert de chansons
françaises moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié
chanter très bien
l'accompagnement musical était au top
voilà donc non vraiment une excellente
initiative
cette opération se déroule dans le cadre
de la fête de la musique une occasion de
promouvoir la culture dans toute sa
richesse et sa diversité
un événement auquel s'associent le
département chaque année
oh